all right
we have
just over a minute left
um
taking my lunch break to watch this day
to play today
potentially timed it around this that
said i have no idea what's in it
absolutely no idea i didn't know it was
happening not a bad um they don't tell a
lowly writer at one studio about a state
of play i promise it doesn't work that
way why on earth would they do that
that's how you get things leaked that
said
it's tokyo game show so i'm expecting
this to have
japanese games um i don't know what
exactly we're going to see obviously i
would love to see silent hill but it's
like
at this point there's no point being
hyped out of my mind for something every
single conference i'm just sort of
shooting myself in the foot and i need
to calm down
like it's just a bit much um
every like game awards i'm like what if
silent hill
it's like you need to pipe down uh it we
could see more for spoken potentially
maybe i don't know that they'll do that
after just having released more gameplay
um
could see final fantasy i don't really
know
i really know but yeah it's tokyo game
show
i believe we're seeing 10 games and this
is gonna last like 20 minutes is what
they said in the playstation vlog
just along for the ride
don't really know what to expect i'd be
shocked if we see bloodborne i do not
think bloodborne is likely
um i don't think that's ever happening
ever again but may i eat my words
wouldn't that be wonderful i would love
to eat my words
all right
let's do it
let me know if the audio is okay because
this is live i can't mix
it's too loud or i'm too loud or
whatever
and it's spiderman
i mean it makes sense
fight
it makes sense it's it makes sense to
start with tekken
[Laughter]
of course yes
this looks good but the stream quality
is like a little bit buffery
unfortunately
beautiful i love fighting
gameplays but like usually they're so
impressive
graphically like a fighting game
cinematic trailer
and unfortunately watching it via stream
is not ideal
the coolest
i don't know why i love
japanese video game characters whoever
wins so much
cool
stay tuned alright
it makes sense not blown away by that
tekken 8 is coming to the playstation 5
console courtesy of our battle hardened
friends at bandai namco entertainment
now let's check in on two games in
development for presents that's right
they did say they'd be psvr hey stop
eating the batmobile
not for you
i wonder how many more details we'll get
on pspr2 i have tried it
um
it was about a certain drug repair and
i'm not allowed to say much about it
business getting into this kind of
trouble other than that i really liked
it
i thought it was very very impressive it
exceeded my experience
i think there are a few new items on the
shelves that might catch your eye
the locals can be a little rough on
tourists but uh it's nothing you can't
handle this is like looks like the kind
of thing we want in we are surely we can
count on you now
oh
hello my friend
it's really hard to do a
vr trailer
that looked pretty cool they look pretty
cool to me
ready for battle
let all monsters beware
my aim is true
it's like a tabletop vr oh my seal
that's cool
[Music]
there are so many games in beyond that
are really awesome that you wouldn't
think are
full-time um but especially things like
rts
where you're so big and it's so small
and you can like lean down and look at
your units and stuff like that rules
[Music]
that's cool
tabletop vr is a really good idea
demio brings the creativity and chaos of
a tabletop rpg to psvr2
because multiplayer which it looks like
there is
from the ground up and will be available
that sounds like japan for the first
time
i didn't expect this to be
such a babe
so hot
damn
i did not think this was gonna be
in this
[Music]
so
um
for anyone who doesn't know this game's
been out in japan for a really long time
and people have wanted it to come to the
west for a really long time because it's
one of the only games in the series that
hasn't
uh
i did already know about this one
nice dude i feel like a lot of people
can be losing their mind about about
this right now i didn't think it would
be in this conference
that's awesome
hello madame mason i understand you have
a shop to sell hogwarts okay i was way
wrong about it being mostly japanese
games generous
what's the catch
you are wise you must be scary
she has had rotten bad luck with the
last few tenants
i think so those who came before you
just could not seem to escape the
darkness
if it's creepy i like it watch your step
wow i'm surprised that that's in here
too i mean that's a really cool trailer
but they delayed the game so i was
surprised that
oh it's a playstation exclusive quest
well that looked rad
anything that's slightly horror i will
take
what's going on little boy
harry potter cycle
what's this what's this what's this what
is this who is this
this fog
could be alan wake
excuse me
oh it could be alone in the dark
the fog got me excited
it's cheating
[Music]
it almost looks like day's gone but i
don't feel like it's graphically
impressive enough to be days gone
[Applause]
warning warning an instability front is
approaching take immediate
stabilized area
locations
i mean it's kind of ghostbustersy but i
don't think this is
ghostbusters
is this vr because the motion sickness
let me tell you
it did look at like that's actually very
on rails
pacific drive is it ps4
caller
now
but that's an ip i haven't heard of
so it's going to be like an on rails car
ps5 okay it's not psbr2
that's pretty unique
survive a ride from hell in pacific
drive the debut game from ironwood
studio cool
up next let's check in
on that now that i know that it's not
yes i'm rolling out soon
what are you doing back there
oh he's just sleeping hi everyone i'm
grace chen not long ago we announced our
brand new loyalty program called
playstation stars it's designed to
celebrate you the players it will be
free to join playstation stars as a
member you can complete various
activities to earn points that can be
redeemed absolutely
digital collectibles are a highlight of
the program these are digital
representations of things that
playstation fans love today i'm pleased
to give you a sneak peek at some
examples of our digital collectibles
sorry i didn't notice
whether it's a beloved game character or
a cherished device from sony's
innovative history there will always be
something new to collect and show off to
your friends
and i have more good news playstation
stars will begin to roll out in some
regions in asia starting in late
september it will launch in the americas
and europe in the weeks that follow
that's it for now check playstation blog
to learn more about playstation stars
okay
this is like very fast this is moving
real quick
[Music]
is
[Music]
but way more combative
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this looks very cool to me
[Music]
this is one of those games that um
i could fall in love with
which is often
like there's always a good chance for me
if it's anything like platinum
these next two intensities like just out
of nowhere completely fall in love with
let's take a look
action games a ps5 console exclusives
okay
vehicle
come on to the vehicle
stray vibes
[Music]
[Music]
does she just have boob physics when
holding that railing
okay it's the whole shirt
and i'm not mad about it
[Music]
do people think that titties move like
that when you walk
because they don't
again
all right with it
but i just need to make sure that the
record is set straight there
we might have seen this game before
because i remember
noticing her but
[Music]
and i think it looks [ __ ] awesome
[Music]
is that like the planet behind
yeah i really want to play this
this looks
incredibly cool to me
the combat looks rad
got some neo vibes project eve that's
right we have seen it before
it's now called
stellar blade that text is very bad
stetter
stell stella that text is very bad
you should maybe reconsider the new logo
reveal
i think that game looks awesome i think
it looks really really really good
um
super into it
definitely like sign me up for that
[Music]
always love to see team ninja after
three centuries of the tokugawa's
repressive rule the black ships appeared
without warning
and our nation began to tear itself
apart
those who cleave to the past
those who embrace the new
and the ronin
a warrior free of all masters and bonds
let's export it
okay
i will watch over you all
as your blades carve a new future
this is like back to back stuff i'm very
into
your time
playstation chat is spamming goes to
tsushima as one no my friends team ninja
it does not make that
yes good yes stop giving me games that i
like
back to back that i'm terrified are
going to be very long
i mean if they can't help that it looks
so sakura there's nothing you can do
about that it's so unfortunate and that
game's so good
but that looked rad
experience an era of great change and
upheaval in rise of the ronin a
sprawling action rpg from team ninja
yes also very good we've got one more
update for you
okay all right didn't know this was
happening today
alrighty then
hello lads
[Music]
i got a blanket when i first joined
santa monica studio that has that little
symbol on it it's so cool
yes don't mind if i do
thank you
everyone keeps secrets
sometimes it's the only way to protect
these trailers just hits so different
it's very very weird
it's really really weird i know you
god killer
what is it you want from
me because i just can't speak just fine
i just can't say anything
like i want to comment and i just have
to be like okay kratos
all that blood on your
hands on your son's hands
what is it you will not tell me
i can't talk about it but i just need
you to trust me
we follow your every whim but you don't
believe in any of it and still i follow
because all that matters is that you are
safe but that's not all that matters
who's keeping you safe
i do not need you i've not seen this
trailer either by the way i haven't
heard about that
pretender god
for the old father death can happen
when it burns me
what do you even know
of god
in your lifetimes has anyone ever seen
just such a weird experience for me
oh man okay can you even imagine that
kind of love no
you don't care about anything beyond
yourself
beyond the monster who kills without
cause
[Music]
it's a good trailer
it's a good trailer
fate only bind you if you let it
[Music]
do what is necessary
not because it is written
wanting to say things i caught
before i said
this is gonna be like a fan of that
thing
that's it we
will make our own destiny
hey
beautiful video game ten out of ten
best game i've ever seen
best trailer i've ever seen um
what more can you want the show what
more could you want i had no idea ps5 at
ps4
no idea or i probably wouldn't have live
streamed it because i just have to sit
here and be like
yeah that's a video game that exists
sick
um that was fun
i feel like they like showed a lot of
stuff that i like some stuff i'm less
interested in that always happens but
mostly stuff i really liked i felt like
it was really fast paced
um
good variety of games way more than i
was expecting
and i hope people um
are excited
to play god of war ragnarok
that's it
was that even 20 minutes it feels like
it was shorter than that
i'm glad you guys liked it people seem
seem positive about
the ragnarok trailer maybe i'll do
another stream today where i watch
people's reactions because that was
really really fun last time
for contacts for anybody who's watching
and doesn't know because that's likely
to happen i work at santa monica studio
that's why i had very little reaction to
that
um
and i'm gonna end the stream now because
i can't comment on it beautiful though
best writing i've ever seen in any video
game you know just
[Laughter]
um all right thanks for watching
everybody thank you for joining me i
will catch up on nintendo after work
today
technically i could do it now
yeah i'm fine with doing it now let me
jump over to because it's still my lunch
break so let's
jump over to the nintendo stream uh no
it's too long it's like a 40 minute
conference i'll do it after work i have
to get back to work or at least have
like more of my lunch break thank you
all for watching
i
will see you guys next time